aunque en varios países occidentales
esta escena de confinamiento parece una
imagen de varios meses atrás aquí en
nueva zelanda sigue estando muy presente
el gobierno extendió tres días el
restrictivo confinamiento de nivel 4
hasta la medianoche del viernes en todo
el territorio en oakland su ciudad más
grande la cuarentena irá hasta el 31 de
agosto para la primera ministra ya sin
la arden este es el camino a seguir
sobre todo para frenar el avance de la
variante delta cuyo primer caso se
detectó el martes de la semana pasada y
ya supera los 100 contagios
esto nos permitirá tener datos
adicionales y asegurarnos sobre si el
virus se está expandiendo desde los
lugares existentes y cómo debería ser la
contención desde el banco central del
país ya están advirtiendo que esta
situación está generando una
incertidumbre económica
y es que en oceanía parece que empieza a
haber un cuestionamiento sobre los
confinamientos australia país vecino
también está manteniendo las cuarentenas
para frenar la variante delta pero en
medio del malestar que ya ha
desencadenado violentas protestas este
fin de semana
queremos ver las cifras de los contagios
bajar y estamos trabajando muy duro para
hacerlo posible
pero en el número en el que tenemos que
centrarnos es el de la tasa de
vacunación sigáis esa situación la de la
vacunación tiene también cierto
paralelismo entre ambos países en nueva
zelanda el 20 por ciento de la población
tiene ya el esquema de vacunación al
completo mientras que en australia la
cifra es de aproximadamente el 30 por
ciento